dernier coup de foudre Alice coup de
foudre mon amoureux quoi
Alice ça va très bien donc vous avez
vous avez tourné avec Alain Delon dans
Frank Riva
de François Armanet et bientôt avec
Édouard Baer
on va faire une interview dernier coup
[Musique]
Alice dernier coup de boule
[Applaudissements]
tête vous voulez dire je sais pas être
là ce soir par exemple on va dire c'est
bien ça
peut-être
ça serait de partir avec Philippe
Lellouche après l'émission ça ce serait
un sacré coup de tête
pourquoi coup de tête
dernier coup de poing
dans une vitre j'étais énervée
comme ça dernier coup de folie non pas
trop non non
direct on est en direct
je pense qu'il vaut mieux que ça donc
voilà mais en même temps c'est pas un
coup de folie je le fais régulièrement
continuez d'en parler quand même un peu
je sais pas moi
c'est-à-dire je sais pas
c'est une histoire qui se termine tout
ça
[Rires]
trop rarement ah bon d'accord
avant de rentrer en scène c'est ça le
dernier coup de cul c'est la question
c'est quoi pour vous un dernier coup de
cul voulait me demander quand je l'ai eu
ou tu sais cet après-midi
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu